[Applause]  armed police  are in pursuit  people are running for their lives  they fear a beating or worse  [Applause]  but during this battle a moment of  breathtaking courage  someone is kneeling in the road  sister anne rosa nutong has stepped  between police and protesters  a  [Music]  oh  the danger is real junta forces killed  18 people in myanmar on sunday  [Applause]  look there's a sister over there  stopping them a shocked reporter says  and being a 45 year old nun doesn't  guarantee  protection  debate  [Music]  after the protest sister and rosa tended  to the injured  among them a journalist cornered  and as the un talks about how to help  myanmar's finding its own heroes  those ready to step up for its people  an ordinary person doing the  extraordinary  against a terrifying military threat  siobhan robbins sky news bangkok